the hangover we've all had one but is  there a cure I'm Fran Kranz I'm dr.  Keller werlin we've created a facility  to test the world's greatest hangover  cures and we're gonna test them all from  the delicious this is my favorite part  so far she's a bizarre that's an eyeball  the ice bath we try out the strangest  hangover remedies on some truly hungover  guests how do you feel today go get that  thing away from me and then share the  results yes post went down to 61 this  supposedly works I'm really happy it's  got a certain amino acid called cysteine  and it actually helps you speed up your  metabolism of alcohol huh welcome to the  GQ hangover lab